빌사남이 간다 오늘은 대학생들의
핫플레이스 건대 입구에 왔습니다
[음악]
네 원래는 화양역이었습니다 근데
건국대학교 요청에 따라서 건대 입구역
역 명칭을 좀 변경을 했고 건대
입구역 같은 경우에는 2호선이 7호선
산승이 있어서 직장인이나 학생들이 어
이용하기 굉장히 좀 좋은 역입니다
그래서 1평균 이용객이 10만 명이
넘을 정도로 이용객들이 굉장히 좀
많고 건대 입구역 같은 경우에는
상권이 좀 세분류로 분류가 될 거
같아요 지금 1번 출구랑 2번 출구
앞에 있는 그 상권 있는 곳이 건대의
맛거리 이제 첫 번째 상권이고 그 두
번째는 건대 로데오거리 이제 6번
출구 앞에 있는 상권이 이제 그
로데오 거리라고 보시면 될 거
같습니다 그리고 좀 더 가서 양꼬치
거리가 있어요네 양꼬치 거리가 있는데
거기는 약간 좀 그 대림동 느낌나는
그런 진짜 좀 양꼬치 음식점이 굉장히
많은 좀 거리라고 보시면 될 거
같습니다 일단 첫 번째로 건대 맛거리
같은 경우에는 건대 메인 상이에요
건대도 되게 높고 공실률도 되게 낮은
곳입니다 그래서 저는 건대에 사신다
그러면 무조건 그 건대 맛거리 그쪽
인근으로 좀 보셔야 되고 거기서도 좀
역에서 그렇게 멀지 않은 곳 거기는
진짜 길마다 상권이 계속 줄어들기
때문에 좀 거기 역 근처에 있는
그쪽에 있는 건물을 좀 투자하시는 걸
좀 권해드리고데 그리고 두 번째로는
그 로데 거리인데 사실 로데오 거리는
좀 분위기가 많이 달라져요 그래서 그
건대 맛거리 좀 분위기가 많이
다릅니다 어 임차 업종도 좀 다르고
여기서부터는 연령층이 조금 더
높아져요 그래서 임차 업종도 봤을 때
대부분 다 이제 음식점이라는 좀 이제
연령층 있는 분들이 좀 이용할 만한
그런 임차 업종들이 좀 많이 몰려
있고 그리고 마지막으로 양꼬치 거리는
사실 여기는 완전 다른 곳이에요
여기는 지금 임대료 수준도 그렇게
높지 않습니다 그 대오 같은 경우에는
한 1층 임대료가 한 10만 원에서
20만 원 정도 되는 거 같아요 근데
이제 양꼬치거리 같은 경우에는 조금
더 낮습니다 진짜 대림동 느낌 나는
진짜 환전소도 있고 거기 제가
놀랬던게 뭐냐면 부동산을 가는데
일단은 그 중국인들 대상으로 이제 그
중국어가 많이 있고 그리고 물건
소개하는게 여기 화양동 소개하는게
아니라 막 저기 부천에 그 중국인들
많은데 있잖아요 그런데 막 홍보물이
막 있더라고요 그래서 되게 놀랬었는데
아무튼 여기 양꼬치 거리는 건대 입구
상권이 좀 좀 다른 곳이라고 보시면
될 거 같습니다 그래서 좀 어르신
분들 중국인 분들 좀 연령층이 있으신
분들이 좀 많이 이용하는 거 같습니다
그래서 오픈업 따르면 거기 주로
매출이 오후
8시부터는 통계의 자료가 나와 있고
그리고 주로 이용하는 고객은 20대
여성분들이 가장 많다라고 합니다
그래서 거기가 그 성수동이 가까워서
상권이 좀 많이 뺏기긴 했지만 그
건대 입구만 그 싼 그 느낌 있거든요
그런 학생들이 좀 많이 찾는 거
같아요 그래서 좀 30대 보다는
20대 좀 젊은 여성분들 비율이 좀
많다라고 보시면 될 거
같습니다네 그래서 이번에도 좀 사례
말씀드릴 건데 일단 건대 그 영화가
있는 건물입니다 그래서 이거는
2018년도에 561억 원에 매입을
했어요 그래서 되게 유명한
자산운용사에서 어 매입을 해서 최근에
기사가 나간게 뭐냐 면 이게 지금
PF 연장이 안 된다 이거 지금 파산
일보 직전이다 뭐 이런 기사들이 좀
났었는데 그래 제가 또 오늘 현장
가서 직접 보니까 정말 위치가 좀 안
좋은데 있습니다 그 양꼬치거리에 가는
길목에 있어요 거기 이면에 500억
이상을 투자할 만한 사람이 없거든요
그래서 지금 뭐 입장을 바꿔서 봤을
때도 내가 만약에 500억짜리 건물을
산다라고 했을 때 일단은 이면은 안
사겠죠 대부분 다 이제 대로변을
사려고 할 텐데 환금성이 좀 되게 많
많이 떨어지는 곳입니다 그 저는 좀
아쉬운게 2018년도에 561억이면
진짜 강남구에서 되게 좋은 대로변도
살 수 있었던 그런 금액인데 물론
그때 당시에 여기가 뭐 지금 영화관도
있고 아마 1 2층도 그때 임대가
들어와 있었을 겁니다 그래서 수익률도
굉장히 좀 좋았을 텐데 근데 지금
상권이 많이 안 좋아지면서 지금 1
2층이 또 공실이 그리고 이제 3
4층이 이제 그 영화관이 들어가
있는데 아마 그거 나가면 더 임대
마치가 어려울 것 같습니다 그리고
요즘에 영화관이 좀 많이 힘들어요
최근에 뭐
넷플릭스라는가 너무 잘돼 있어 가지고
그 집에서 진짜 쉽게 보잖아요네 쉽게
이제 영화 시청도 되기 때문에 좀
이런 영화관들이 좀 되게 매우 힘든
상태입니다 그래서 개인적으로는 제가
사례를 좀 정하긴 했는데 좀 안타까운
그런 건물이지 않나네 그렇게 보고
있습니다네 그래서 건물투자 팁을 좀
말씀드리면 일단 첫번째로 대상이 때
의 그 단가가 낮아요 그래서 한번
제가 현장 가서도 봤지만 진짜 뭐
맥주 뭐 1900원 안주 뭐 6천
얼마 만 원 뭐 안주거리 뭐 이것
때문에 단가 자체가 낮기 때문에
임대료 수준이 그렇게 높지 않습니다
저희가 막 그 전에 봤었던 뭐 로데오
아든 성수동이 아든 용리단 길이라는
이런 그니까 30대 분들 막 직장인들
돈 쓰시는 분들이 팍팍 쓰는 그런
상권이 아니기 때문에 대학생들 상권은
대체적으로 임대 수준이 좀 낮습니다
그렇기 때문에 여러분들이 만약에 이전
대학가에 투자한다고 하면 어 단가
때문에 아무래도 올리는데 좀 한계가
있다네 이렇게 보시면 될 거 같고 그
두 번째로 권리금이 형성이 돼
있어요네 권리금이 다 형성이 돼
있어서 나중에 임차인 명도하지 뭐
그런 부분 때문에 좀 이슈가 있을 수
있습니다 그래서 그런 메인 상권 같은
경우에는 권리금 문제가 좀 있다
그리고 이제 세 번째로는 리금 때문에
임대료를 높게 못 받고 있는 건물들이
많아요 메인 상권에 있는 건물 같은
경우에는 그냥 명도만 시켜 놔도
임대료를 높게 올릴 수 있습니다
왜냐면 권리금 때문에 이제 인차
들끼리 막 매장을 판 거예요 계속
계속 팔면서 그 임대료 수준이
대체적으로 좀 낮을 수가 있습니다
권리금이 없는 건물들은 임차인
입장에서 봤을 때 권리금이 없는데
차라리 임대를 높게 주는게 낫잖아요
그래서 그런 부분 때문에 이렇게 메인
상권에 권리금이 많은 건물 같은
경우에는 좀 임대료 수준이 낮을 수
있다 그래서이 명도만 시켜도 임대료를
좀 높게 올릴 수 있다네 이렇게
보시면 될 거 같습니다 그리고 이런
메인 상건 건물 같은 경우에는 따로
손을 많이 안 봐도 돼요네 리모델링을
많이 안 해도 어차피 임차인들이
들어와서 인테리어를 많이 합니다 진짜
그냥 임차인만 명도하고 그 공간만 좀
잘 만들어 주면 굳이 내가 공사 안
해도 임차인이 와서 다 이제 공사도
해 준다 어 이렇게 보시면 될 거
같습니다
그리고 건대 입구 같은 경우에는 제가
20대가 많이 온다 그랬는데
20대만이 상권이 유지되기가 좀
어려울 것 같아요 그리고 앞으로 좀
저출산 이런 문제도 있기 때문에 건대
입구역 상권이 어찌 됐든 좀
살아나려면 건대 구역만 뭔가 특징이
있어야 돼요 그니까 이제 외부에서
사람들이 올만한 이유를 만들어 줘야
되 된다라고 생각합니다 그래서 최근에
좀 보면은 건대입구역 앞에 그 청춘
락이라고 있어요 그래서 약간 버스킹
할 수 있는 그런 공간을 만들어
놨습니다 좀 이렇게 건대입구역에 올
만한 좀 이유를 만들어 줘야 돼요
근데 이제 건대 입구 같은 경우에는
누구나 다 볼 만한 그런 임차인들이
많이 있기 때문에 좀 특색을 더 살릴
필요가 있지 않나 싶긴 합니다 그리고
이제 추가적으로 외국인도 좀 갈 만한
그런 요소를 만들어야 될 것 같아요
최근에 이제 한국의 외국인 관광객들이
굉장히 많아지면서 외국인에 따라서
상권이 좀 많이 변화하기도 합니다 그
외국인을 올만한 요소를 어떤 걸
만드느냐에 따라서 진짜
상권의 그런 승패가 자지 우지도 하는
거
같아요네 오늘은 어 젊은 사람들의
핫플레이스 건대 입구로 좀
다녀왔습니다 그리고 저희 이제
빌사남이 간다 다음 편은 뉴욕을
준비했습니다 그래서 어 요번 주에 갈
예정인데 어 뉴욕도 약간 재밌는
공간들이 너무 많고 촬영할 만한게
정말 많아요 그래서 저희가 좀 되게
야심차게 준비를 했고 사나미 간다
뉴욕 폰도 여러분들 기대하셔도 좋을
것 같습니다네이 영상이 아마 8월
23일 날 올라갈 예정인데 만약에
내가 뉴욕에서 궁금한 곳이 있다
여러분들 댓글 남겨 주시면 제가
뉴욕을 갔다가 어 그곳을 참고해서
한번 좀 촬영해 보도록 하겠습니다
그래 오늘 영상 여기까지 하고요은
불사
[음악]
turn and
r i to make
you you sp me right
Call me when your
time Run out I know